let's talk about who could be the next
president of Nigeria
and race
this guy is really shaking things up
Nigerians have signed up to vote in
record numbers ahead of election day
February 25th after eight tough years
under President muhammadu buhari a lot
of people feel a lot needs to change
it's a crucial vote for Nigerians
Africa's most populous nation faces a
worsening economic and security
situations we are tired of all these
years in darkness and suffering we must
vote right and we must vote wisely so
who are the main candidates why is the
presidential election so different and
why is it so hard to predict a winner
[Music]
Nigeria's Got the biggest population in
Africa 213 million people half of them
are under 19 and it's incredibly diverse
it's got more than 250 ethnicities
around 500 languages and it's more or
less half Muslim half Christian there's
also a geographical Dimension to that
religious split so broadly speaking the
north is where more Muslims are from and
the south is more Christian and this big
cross-cutting mix of ethnicity religion
and Regional identity underpins a lot of
Nigeria's politics people always have a
tendency to look more favorable to the
person who speaks their language who
understands their culture now usually
the presidential election comes down to
a choice between the two candidates from
the two main parties the people's
Democratic party the PDP and the all
progressives Congress APC for short
and usually those parties field
candidates that fit with an Unwritten
rule where the presidency rotates
between a Christian from the south and a
Muslim from the north which is what
president buhari is so that pattern
would suggest the next president should
be a Christian from the south which
neither of the two main candidates are
for starters we've got Ebola tinubu for
the ruling APC he's the former governor
of Lagos and he's from the south
although he's Muslim then there's atiku
abubakar a former vice president who's
the PDP candidate he's also Muslim but
from the north now some people think
that this break with the usual pattern
risks making religion and ethnicity an
even bigger issue in this election than
usual
we look very very ethnic as people vote
along Regional lines
and religious life so everybody is
either thinking it's silos that look
this is our tone we have to support one
of our own while the young people are
saying that there has to be a
generational change and what young
people are thinking is a huge part of
this election because a lot of them are
getting behind a third Contender Peter
Obi and having three Front Runners is a
first Obi is a Christian from the south
and was governor of a number of State a
job a lot of people think he did quite
well and he ran for vice president for
the PDP in 2019. now he's running for
the labor party and even though he's in
his 60s and super wealthy he's seen by
his supporters as more Dynamic and More
in tune with what younger people want
unlike your average
in every sense of whoa and Peter B is
regularly seen carrying his own
briefcase pairing his own bags and
joining the Queue at airports this is
what so it appeals to peace and then
he's accessible people can approach him
he doesn't
move around with huge convoys like your
average Guardian variety Nigerian
politician he has actually brought up
the excitement but importantly is also
given the dominant party and run for
their money so they can no longer afford
to sit and being
those out and one of the reasons for
that is how the vote works because to
win the presidency the candidate has to
get a majority of the overall National
vote but they also have to win at least
25 percent of the vote in two-thirds of
Nigeria's 36 States plus the federal
capital territory home to the capital
Abuja that's to make sure the president
has a spread of support across the
country
so with three candidates in the mix it's
much harder for any of them to win
outright but there's another guy too
I like the city of surroundings
because there's a fourth candidates who
not many good about grab you one
question
is a Muslim from the North and the
former Governor of Kano state he
probably doesn't have the national
appeal needed to actually win but he's
very popular in the north and that could
further split the vote for the other
three candidates and all of this means
the presidential election May well go to
a second round we don't see a situation
where anybody would guess that required
spread and we don't see a situation
where anybody would get the
um the 50 50 plus one that is required
to win so which means that will be
looking at the runoff for the first time
in Nigeria's history so right now the
race is looking wide open and turnout is
expected to be high the election
commission says 10 million new voters
have registered 84 percent of them are
under 34. the candidate will probably
benefit most from that is Peter Obi and
he's the favorite in pretty much every
poll
but polls in Nigeria can be misleading
and some people are questioning whether
all the hype around OB will actually
translate into votes either because he's
over hyped or for other reasons one
thing that pools cannot consider is for
example the Dynamics of Nigeria's
electoral process when people go to
cooling units and somebody lives in word
of cash attack what happens then so
regardless of one's Grassroots
popularity if all the forces of an
incumbency and control and and money
flowing of course as well are stacked
against you like they appear to be
stacked against Peter Obi then it's
going to be very difficult for him to
essentially compete on a Level Playing
Field whoever ends up taking over from
president buhari is going to be under
pressure to deal with some really
serious and Urgent problems the economy
is tanking there's widespread corruption
and 40 percent of Nigerians live below
the poverty line
and it's the poorest who are hit hardest
by the major security issues which in
recent years have spread to almost every
part of the country
[Music]
and an isil affiliate group in the north
violence between farmers and herders
fighting over land kidnappings by
criminal gangs
armed groups stealing oil
and separatists fighting in the
southeast
there is a sense both among Nigerians
and long-time Nigeria Watchers like
myself that Nigeria's on a on an
extremely worrying path at the moment
and so here we have potentially a a last
or or near to last opportunity to really
turn the ship around baby is a
despondence there is a feeling of like
oh yes these status filled the people
are not feeling the impact of democracy
and these elections them represent an
opportunity to again renegotiate this
democracy and see if it can bring
development to the people
here